el acuerdo
entre los ministros de asuntos
exteriores de reino unido y de irlanda
en kigali la capital del país de este
pacto estipula que cualquier persona que
llega ilegalmente al reino unido será
llevada a ruanda a menos que pueden
demostrar legalmente ante los tribunales
ingleses que no estarían seguros en el
país de llegada a luanda que debería
recibir inicialmente 120 millones de
libras esterlinas ha impuesto ciertas
condiciones como el rechazo de niños y
menores hay que decir que esta firma
provocó reacciones muy críticas en
inglaterra en particular el partido
laborista de la oposición que calificó
el acuerdo de inviable y poco ético por
su parte de actuar en gabari presidenta
de un partido de la oposición grandeza
pidió que el país siempre en resolver
sus problemas políticos y sociales en
vez de recibir
extranjeros